elle la douche froide pour les qu'ovide
sceptiques
chassés de leur terrain de jeu le ton
qui monte
certains manifestants à terre menotté
ce dimanche les forces de l'ordre
appelées en renfort à la veille
d'élections législatives déterminantes
entre intimidations et parfois
répression
[Applaudissements]
un ordre d'urgence lancé par la police
pour disperser la foule et faire
respecter les règles sanitaires
le gouvernement du premier ministre mark
rutte eux en ligne de mire la coalition
au pouvoir composée de quatre par qui a
décidé de serrer progressivement la vis
depuis mi décembre
aujourd'hui le pays est sous couvre feu
jusqu'au 31 mars
de 21h à 4h30 du matin l'eau coronavirus
sujet numéro un de tension de
frustration depuis plusieurs semaines
mais les politiques néerlandais souhaite
aborder d'autres sujets je pense que la
réponse honnête et qu'après la fin de
l'épisode du coronavirus de nombreux
problèmes que nous avions seront de
nouveau sur la table avec une revanche
en terme de création d'une économie
solidaire ajustée mais aussi forte de
construction d'une société sûre et
sécurisée
je pense que ça devrait être l'enjeu de
ces élections d'alourdir la chine est ce
que matthew goode corbett
on parle trop ducobu dans quel que ça
alors que ces élections sont un moment
nous devons décider qui est un tournant
en termes d'investissements importants
nécessaires pour l'éducation les emplois
du futur l'économie vers et comme je les
mentionnaient la lutte contre la crise
climatique d'autres partis pendent
encore pouvoir espère jouer la carte de
la fidélité comme la deuxième formation
du pays celle de guerre builders avec
pour principal axe de campagne
l'immigration sans oublier la
problématique du futur l'écologie porté
par jessy clever 34 ans nous voulons
rejoindre la coalition
nous aimerions travailler avec tous les
autres partis de gauche et les partis
progressistes pour nous assurer qu'il y
aura un gouvernement de gauche vers un
gouvernement vert est aussi un
gouvernement pro européen afin que le
changement que nous préconisons dans
cette campagne nous puissions le
réaliser al'approche des élections le
premier ministre marque route eux a
autorisé début mars la réouverture des
salons de coiffure et massage ainsi que
celle partielle des lycées et collèges
les magasins dits non essentielles
peuvent aussi accueillir
un maximum de deux clients sur rendez
vous l'intérieur des restaurants et bars
reste cependant toujours fermé